[Musique]
cyrille melchior s'est rendu ce même
produit 25 avril à saint-andré où il a
visité accompagné du recteur vellaye
odom marimoutou et de l'adjoint au maire
de saint-andré et vice président du
département jean marie virapoullé le
collège joseph bédier particulièrement
touché par le météore c'est à dire que
l'eau les boîtes ont ravi les routes
les dégâts sont exceptionnelles de la
boue et des détritus ce du matériel
cassé les produits toxiques ont été
charriés par l'eau rendant les classes
inexploitables et il n'a pas à
accueillir des collégiens comme nous
l'expliquent monsieur cyrille melchior
président du département
quand on voit les dégâts qui ont été
occasionnés à saint-andré au collège le
département se doit d'être présent nous
allons donc très rapidement donner les
moyens ce collège de fonctionner d'abord
en procédant au nettoyage à la remise en
état des locaux
deuxième problème c'est le matériel qui
a été abîmée bureau mais aussi du
matériel informatique des matériels de
laboratoire
nous allons intervenir en direct et s'il
le faut je suis prêt à dialoguer l'aise
qu'on lui donne une dotation
exceptionnelle d'équipements pour moi ce
qui compte c'est intervenir rapidement
parce que il y à des examens bientôt
quoi ces jeunes collégiens et bien il ne
faut pas retarder leur scolarité
c'est pour ça que le département met en
oeuvre des moyens pour que les cours
puissent reprendre rapidement dans le
collège à saint-andré
[Musique]